we're going to start the show with a
hostage tanking in the Eastern German
city of Dresden police have found the
body of a woman there in her apartment
this morning with her 40 year old son
suspected of killing her they say he
then took hostages in a shopping center
in the city police evacuated the mall
and its surrounding areas including a
Christmas Market which was closed
they've cleared people away from the
city center and shortly before we came
on air police reported that the hostages
are unhurt and that the suspect has been
injured and is in their custody
joining me here now in the studio is
DW's political correspondent Benjamin
Alvarez group of Benjamin hi there what
more can you tell us about what's
unfolding
police was in contact with the
perpetrator already who was in the
shopping mall they said they have two
hostages they appear to be unharmed they
are of course still ambulances on the
scene because you have to do the medical
checks first and they said that even
though this hostage situation is no over
they confirm that they have the
perpetrator also they captured him as
well but it will take a time for this
area that has been coordinate of in the
central a part of Dresden II of course
let this examiners also look into
exactly what happened to follow what was
the path of this perpetrator today talk
to us more about the area where this is
where this all took place and the
significance of that so it is in the
center of Tristan but what this media
report what you also mentioned with the
body of this woman that was founded in
the southern suburbs of atres and there
was this is a radio station it's called
radio Dresden it's a small private radio
station that's located close to Dresden
Central Station so pretty close also to
the old part of the city of Dresden
that's the media information that we
have but they also confirmed that it's
not true that the perpetrator actually
managed to get into The Newsroom there
were some reports that were not
confirmed by police as well but what we
have from police is the perpetrator is
already in custody that both hostages
that are also with police right now seem
to be unharmed the investigations will
be ongoing also to see how there is a
relation between the death of the matter
of the suspected perpetrator and what
happened after what this hostage
situation now Benjamin this is obviously
a very busy time of year Christmas is
just around the corner lots and lots of
people are out and about how has that
affected what police have been doing in
the in the city center so actually
taking it very cautiously and they
closed also one of the Christmas Market
it's nearby this shopping center where
this hostage situation happened and if
we look back only a few years in
brightshat plus it was a pretty big
terrorist attack and now looking around
and going going to the Christmas markets
you can see that there's also protection
against trucks who may be able to go in
there so there is indeed concern when it
comes to possible hostage situations
when it comes to this perpetrators and
of course they have to take this
situation very very very carefully and
tell people on one side to be careful to
don't spread fake news that's something
that unfortunately we see a lot
happening after these situations to
follow the instructions of the police
and the police have said that even
though this hostage situation is over it
might take a time for them to be able to
reopen the shopping center now Benjamin
this is all off the back of some very
significant security threats that have
come to light in the last few days here
in Germany talk to us about that if you
could
the happen indeed rates that's about the
reisberger that's a group that is in the
eye of security of domestic intelligence
Services also of Germany's interior
Minister I mean they planned a coup on
the German government we have no idea if
this is related so they would be going
into speculation that exactly what
police it don't want media to do but
there is indeed concern that there might
be people who are planning this kind of
attack so even if this case
we see that it was a single person who
acted we don't know yet if there are
other people who were involved with this
planning overall so trying to plan
something together with this there is
indeed concerned by the domestic
intelligence Services by the interior
Ministry to look and to try to avoid
these type of situations that was our
political correspondent Benjamin Alvarez
Gruber speaking to us about this hostage
taking in the Eastern German city of
Dresden of course this is a story we're
going to be following throughout the
afternoon here on DW Benjamin thank you
as always